hi I'm Eric Voss and Game of Thrones
season 7 is coming and it looks like
we're going to get some huge payoff in
these final episodes but it's easy to
forget that there are actually a lot of
unresolved questions and mysteries that
Game of Thrones still needs to explain
some are interesting implications of
recent bombshell and others are
lingering loose ends or bizarre moments
from the past that no one ever really
followed up on so in this video I'm
going to talk about the biggest
questions in ways that the show might
answer them and spoiler warning just in
case any of my predictions or theories
end up coming true ok let's start with
Jon Snow we now know that he is half
Targaryen the son of Ned Stark's sister
Lyanna and the Prince Rhaegar Targaryen
so the question is what exactly does
that Targaryen lineage mean for him now
so if Liana and Rhaegar were married
that would make Jon in a way heir to the
Iron Throne at least using the argument
that Daenerys is using that Robert
Baratheon was an illegitimate usurper
and that the throne still legally
belongs to the Targaryen dynasty
and if Jon is a non bastard son of the
crown prince of that dynasty his claim
to the throne is even slightly stronger
than Daenerys is so if this truth
becomes public knowledge will that herds
and heiresses campaign to reclaim the
throne and will that make her and John
enemies not to say that John wants the
Iron Throne but will Daenerys see him as
a threat or looking at things more
optimistically since they're family now
will their bloodlines bring them closer
together and in the eyes of the reigning
monarch Cersei will this now be a second
Targaryen orphan that she has to face on
the battlefield meanwhile from another
perspective if John's Targaryen
background becomes public in the north
will that make it an enemy to his fellow
northerners remember all these northern
Lords and their families followed the
Starks into a war against the Targaryen
I could see this creating some tension
remember a little lady Lyanna Mormont
and the rest swore fealty to Jon on the
basis that Ned Stark's blood runs
through his veins and yeah even though
he still had stark blood from his mother
Leanna maybe needs northerners will be
sticklers about it ok you don't know
where you go Leana storks blood and
dragon blood we have no king really I'm
just curious to know what Jon's real
name it it was hard to read Lana's lips
than that season finale scene it looks
like it began with an
a sound so I'm guessing maybe some
Targaryen a name like Aegon or Amon or
Aerys we've also speculated that could
it be Harris which would connect John to
an interesting parallel figure in the
Targaryen family history actually check
out our season finale breakdown for more
information on that but let me know in
the comments do you think John's
Targaryen blood will get them in trouble
and let's move on to brand so what the
hell can brand do exactly so last season
revealed that brand now has the powers
of the three-eyed Raven he can connect
with weirwood trees to glimpse into
moments in the past like the Kingslayer
moment or in the future like wildfire
destroying the set but the mystery here
lies in whether or not bran is able to
change those events so remember in the
heartbreaking hold the door episode
brand warmed into Hodor his mind as a
boy making him hold the door in the
present day so they could escape and
this choice by brand proved to be the
origin of Hodor constantly mumbly in the
nonsense word of Hodor throughout his
life and then in another time jump when
bran looked at the Tower of joy he
called out to his father and Ned turned
around as if you heard of so does this
mean that bran has the power to change
the path or something like a real time
travel nerd for a second has brand
already changed some things in the past
like maybe at some point in the future
he will go back to cause things that
have already happened
I talked previously about the theories
of brand turning the Mad King mad for
example whispering the phrase burning
them all to him also the idea that bran
Stark could be the ancient bran the
Builder who built the wall thousands of
years ago another theory is that the man
whom we saw transform into the first
white Walker could be bran as an adult
meaning brand could be the knife King on
about that but we'll talk more about the
night King later really I could talk
about the implications of time travel
for hours but let's not forget that bran
is also a ward you can control the minds
of animals even magical ones like dire
wolves and yes this could mean that we
will see brand warg into a dragon
remember at the end of season 4 the
three-eyed Raven made this cryptic
promise you live awoke again
but you will sign now this could refer
to Brandis flying through a different
winged animal or like flying through
time and envision or just him taking on
the title of the three-eyed Raven
but yeah dragon bran is way cooler I'm
team Graham done anyway let me know in
the comments all the crazy ways that you
want to see brand uses powers let's move
on to another mystery probably the
biggest mystery on the show now who is
adora hi reborn aka the prince that was
promised so the prophecy of azor Ahai
reborn also referred to as the prince
was promised refers to a character
destined to vanquish the White Walkers
this person is supposed to be born
beneath a bleeding star amidst salt and
smoke they also carry a flaming sword
called light bringer that was forged in
a unique way and some interpreters say
that the figure is probably going to be
born from the Targaryen bloodline and
associated with dragon so obviously the
person who best fits this profile is
Daenerys glad if you care less about the
dragon aspect of it and more about the
sword part of it Jon Snow could also be
a prime candidate and then of course I
made another video recently where I
explained that reddit theory that Jaime
Lannister could be azor Ahai I've
actually had a series of videos in the
works that makes cases for other
characters but of course this could just
be the case where we never find out
george RR martin has said that he made
Game of Thrones as a response to classic
good versus evil chosen ones stories
that glorify war so this whole prophecy
might just be more interesting as a way
to explore character like Stannis
Baratheon was way more compelling as a
man who firmly believed that he was a
prophecy figure but then ultimately
wasn't and actually the same goes for
Cersei Lannister who's obsessed with her
own prophecies so will Circe's prophecy
be fulfilled so in the show Cersei was
told as a girl that she will have three
children with golden hair and golden
shrouds meaning they'll die prematurely
and as of the season six finale check
Cersei was also told that she would be
queen but that she would be overthrown
by a younger more beautiful Queen and at
different points Cersei with paranoid
that could be Sansa and then later more
likely Margaery Tyrell and then as of
the season six finale and gnash but
obviously there is another younger more
beautiful Queen on the way who poses a
much bigger threat to Cersei power Yara
Greyjoy
I mean come on she should be a queen
you're on Greyjoy is hashtag not my rule
of the Iron Islands
no but seriously seriously look out
because Daenerys Targaryen is on her way
to destroy you but I can honestly see
either of those two powerful women
Daenerys or Yara fulfilling Cersei
prophecy I also wouldn't count out
either the stark girl
Sansa or Arya the river Cersei is still
at the top of Arya's wishlist and Arya
has proven with Walder Frey that she can
infiltrate castles and assassinate High
Lords and bake their sons in the pies
now in the book the prophecy also
includes a bit about Cersei dying at the
hands of the Valen car younger brother
suggesting that Jaime or Tyrion might
end up killing her now I've gone over
this a lot actually go check out our
Jaime Lannister theory video for more
thoughts on that or just Jaime in
general and let me know who you think is
or Ahai reborn will be and your thoughts
on Circe's prophecy and whether Game of
Thrones needs to fulfill these down in
the comments but let's move on to the
other Lannister sibling Tyrion so how
was Tyrion able to face Daenerys dragons
without getting burned alive notice how
the Dragons rhaegal and Viserion steamed
shockingly tame around Tyrion and we've
speculated in the past that the reason
could be that Tyrion has Targaryen blood
- that's right
everyone's a Targaryen so the
interesting theory is that while Tywin
Lannister was hand to the Mad King the
Mad King could have conceived a child
with Tywin's wife Joanna Lannister who
later died giving birth to Tyrion and
that might further explain why I Lynn
always treated Tyrion is less than a son
it could also explain why Tyrion had
such natural bonds with Jon and Daenerys
whom he would be related to if this
theory is true more possible evidence
for this is in the book in Daenerys
envisioned in the house of the undying
and she heard the phrase the dragon has
three heads which you could interpret to
mean that there will be three Targaryen
Daenerys John and someone else maybe
Tyrion
all writing these three dragons like
their ancestor Aegon the Conqueror and
his sisters did during the conquest and
if you look closely at that final shot
in the season 7 trailer there does look
like there's a barely noticeable figure
on Grogan's back and some people said
that could be Tyrion but then again I
don't know how you would distinguish
what that bump is also earlier in the
trailer there's a shot of Tyrion looking
up as the three drew
against fly past him so just could be
foreshadowing something but comment down
below and let me know what you think
about this theory really I'm just
curious to see where Tyrion ends up I
want him to be on the Iron Throne I want
him to find that first wife of his Caixa
who's still out there somewhere
and mostly I just want him to finally
get to the punchline of that joke I once
brought a jackass and a honeycomb into a
brothel I once walked into a brothel
with a honeycomb and a jackass the madam
says but moving on another character in
spate I'm curious about is aria
specifically will Aria ever go west of
Westeros remember last season there was
this almost forgettable moment where
Aria briefly mentions to the actress
lady crane that she might someday like
to explore the West of Westeros ssds
Electress is West that was left of
Westeros I don't know nobody does and
this is pretty interesting because the
concept of Westeros has been compared in
the past to the countries of Europe like
England and Scotland Spain and Italy and
just like the people that old world used
to wonder about what was on the other
side of the sea the Americas what if
there's a whole other world off to the
west of Westeros will Arya leave that
global expedition and since george RR
martin has said that the world of Game
of Thrones is round will Arya be the one
to discover that the northern lands of
always winter actually connects to the
far eastern part of Essos I don't know I
didn't love maps I want to see them
filled out okay moving on to someone who
might join Arya on this road trip of
sorts her direwolf 'no mario what
happened to gnam area sonam area
disappeared from the show back in season
1 and over the seasons all the other
starts our wolves have dired off lady
gray wind shaggy-dog and summer now it's
just john's direwolf ghost and gnam area
wherever she is now in the books the
dire wolves have had way more symbolic
significance to the stark family they're
smarter and way larger and they have
more personality and they because that's
a weirdly magical force it's actually
kind of implied that all the starved
children share a telepathic connection
with the animal so not just bran who is
definitely a warg but Robb and gray wind
were described
as one in the same on the battlefield
and in the books aria dreams through in
America's eyes as the direwolf leads the
pack of wolves and Riverland now on the
show the dire wolves are kind of played
down they're depicted more as loyal pets
who make us really sad whenever they die
so will Aria ever seen Ameria again will
reuniting with a dire will be part of an
emotional homecoming sequence like a
reverse homeward bound or will this
reunion be more badass like Aria in the
middle battle with White Walkers
alongside dragon bran
discovering her own warg abilities when
her long locks dire wolf appears I think
I just turned Game of Thrones in a
Pokemon okay moving on the other long
lost Aria companion is Gendry so where
the hell is Gendry then and are his arms
super jacked from rowing back and forth
across the Narrow Sea for three seasons
so Gendry the blacksmith's apprentice
who is also secretly the bastard son of
Robert Baratheon he was last seen
departing Dragonstone at the end of
season three and actually according to
rumors actor Joe Dempsey has been
spotted in Belfast where Game of Thrones
a shot and if you look closely at this
shot in the season 7 trailer I pointed
out how this character is holding a
Warhammer now the Warhammer is the
famous weapon of choice by Robert
Baratheon ginjuries father so I know
just pointing to a weapon and saying
that the character is kind of a stretch
but maybe this is Gendry here joining
Jon Snow and the others against the
White Walkers anyway let me know in the
comments if you think I'm crazy ok
moving on to two of the most mysterious
figures a Game of Thrones
who are impressively still alive first
Littlefinger's specifically how much
does Littlefinger know I pointed out in
the past that Littlefinger might know
the truth about Jon's parentage which
could be why we see Jon shoving
Littlefinger against the wall in the
Winterfell crypts in the trailer but the
bigger mystery here is how would
Littlefinger know that I mean sure he
does have informants all over Westeros
but if Littlefinger knew that Ned
Stark's bastard was really the royal son
of Prince Rhaegar Targaryen
little figure would also probably know
that the whole basis of Robert's
rebellion Lyanna being kidnapped was
actually a lie and this is where I get
paranoid because we know that it was a
little finger who manipulated Lysa Arryn
in
to poisoning her husband and then
blaming the Lannisters for the sole
purpose of creating a conflict between
the Lannisters and the Starks
so that little finger could capitalize
on that chaos chaos so what if it was
Littlefinger behind the earlier war as
well Robert's rebellion notice how it
did end up with him climbing the ladder
to become the master of coin so do you
think Littlefinger could be behind all
of this comment weigh in let me know now
the other mysterious figure that I
mentioned is various and the biggest
question I have about this guy is what
the hell is going on with that wizard in
a box okay don't ask only if you don't
know what I'm talking about in season 2
Varys told hearing about the sorcerer
who tortured him as a boy and how he
later tracked down the old man and kept
him alive in a crate so we know that
Varys in general looks down on torture
and claims to do everything for the good
of the realm
specifically the orphan children like he
was so how does torture in an old wizard
in a wooden crate fit in with all that
when's he gonna let Dumbledore out of
the box okay old man I'll let you out
but no funny business Oh rats
you transform themselves into a chicken
why did I do that
so another mystery that I'm curious
about involves the religions of Westeros
which of these many gods is the true God
now we've seen several different face on
the show and more than one of them have
shown their own kind of divine power
there are the old gods who are still
worship in the North they've been kind
of legitimized now that their weirwood
trees the three-eyed Raven and the
children of the forest all have shown to
have legit magic meanwhile the followers
of the Lord of Light a monotheistic
religion from Essos have successfully
resurrected more than one person from
the dead so I would also say that's a
miracle
then there's the drowned god of the Iron
Islands who also has had some kind of
resurrection power remember every time
they baptize someone they're technically
drowning them first then there's the
many-faced God of the faceless men who
seemed mystic and divine at first but
now we know that that magic is based
more on sleight of hand and superfast
wardrobe changes now the most
traditional and widespread of these
religions in Westeros is the new gods
these seven but they along with the
Dothraki worship of the great stallion
kind of went up in smoke literally and
then there's this obscure deity that
bears brought up one time
they worship the fertility goddess with
16 teats
sounds legit to me so I'm curious to see
how the two currently most powerful
religions on the show the Lord of Light
and the old gods are reconciled
specifically there's so much we don't
know about characters like kin vara the
High Priestess of the Lord of Light
there's also that mysterious Riddler
character from the same city that can
borrows from a shy but her name was
Quast the shadow binder does she have
any connection to the Lord of lights is
she ever coming back you could tell us
how she made that awesome mask we
actually loved to make another video
that dives deep into all these different
religions on the show but in the
meantime let me know what you think in
the comments and moving on to the final
big unresolved mystery of Game of
Thrones what exactly do the White
Walkers want so last season we finally
got some big information about the White
Walkers or the others as they're known
the books they were created by the
children of the forest as a white weapon
of mass destruction during the war with
men so we now know how they were created
but what do they hope to achieve or do
they just have no goals other than they
kill everything in sight like evil ice
terminators sure it does seem like Game
of Thrones is heading towards an epic
battle of good versus evil with the men
finally joining forces to face off
against these supernatural weapons of
war but now that I say that I feel like
the george RR martin version of that war
would end with like the white walkers
just winning and the knight king sitting
on the Iron Throne and getting his balls
stuck to it so taking it outside of the
box and all the other alternate ways
this could go the theory that makes the
most sense to me is that the knight
king's goal is to do what every
artificial instrument of destruction
inevitably does meet his maker and
destroy him so how would the knight king
destroy the children of the forest like
aren't they all already dead well maybe
not according to legend in the middle of
the Gods I lake is the Isle of faces now
this is a sacred historical site where
the children the forest and men agreed
to the pact that ended their war the
island is supposed to be covered in
weirwood trees and no one goes there
other than a group of caretakers called
the green men and I think that some
remaining children of the forest might
be there too and this could be
where the night king and his white
walker army are headed to finish off the
children of the force in fact that might
be why the White Walkers keep making
this spiral pattern in the snow which
remember reflects the pattern of these
stones surrounding the weirwood tree
where the night king was created could
be a warning from the night king that he
remembers the day that the children of
the forest doomed him to this life of
endless torment and now that I'm looking
at the shops I'm wondering that this
weirwood tree where the night king was
created might be on the Isle of faces
and maybe brand second vision of it
where it was all frozen over is a look
into the future when winter has covered
all of Westeros tonight which could
happen in season seven and eight and
maybe the White Walkers have returned to
their original home smack in the middle
of Westeros okay okay fair enough I may
have pushed you too far with that theory
it's just so much mystery with White
Walkers in my mind it's going to weird
places but what do you think the White
Walkers and goal is and what other
unresolved questions do you want to see
answered in these final two seasons and
also remember to weigh in on those other
questions about Jon brands aura hi
Cersei Tyrion Arya and all the rest and
get your friends to weigh in on this
stuff too you can like this video and
share it around and you can tweet any
thoughts or questions to me directly a
TA boss or at new rock stars at new rock
stars this channel is actually going to
start doing some giveaways on Twitter so
make sure to follow us and of course
subscribe to new rockstars we got some
really great game of Thrones content
that works you're gonna love it and you
can actually have a say in what videos
we make here by contributing to us on
patreon thank you so much to all of our
current patrons especially Wilhelmina
Edison okay thanks for watching it damn
it
varus's box wizard got out again I was
getting in the food there is this is on
you
[Music]
you
[Music]